[Music]
a little bit of work man that don't
scare us i get up i go hard like i'm
george harris make plays break lanes
push way
[Music]
this is where we cover three of you know
i'd say important fights for you so
we're gonna kick this off with your
first fight in the ufc
which this is a hell of a way to make
your debut in the ufc because
for the the fans watching this show
right now
if you don't know who uh jacob volkman
is he was a monster so for your first
fight it's not like you're getting
another guy who's debuting or anything
like that i think jacob
either is on an eight or nine win yeah
yeah i think it was an eight one like
not an easy debut
so you so weird and so we're starting
the third round you lost the first one
the second we're heading to third
for your debut fight but how did this
fight even come to like how how did the
ufc call all that stuff oh so
strikeforce at the time was in business
and ended up shutting down business
deals of ufc bought them out correct so
they only kept a certain amount of
fighters
um sean shelby was a matchmaker at the
time
and so
my manager told me a little story he's
like
they were having so much trouble with
vogue because bacon's the epitome of
shoot yourself in the [ __ ] head you
know he was a he's an interesting cat
like yeah he was like was he was he uh
oh you want them was he like there's the
mic was he like anti i because he would
always do rants like political rants
right
like he was like anti he was the king of
chris
that's right yeah yeah he he wasn't
exactly the most marketable guy but he
would win yeah so ufc's like we gotta
get this guy out of here man [ __ ] man
and so i remember seeing him i'm like
we got a black president and he just
disrespecting them so much they're like
get rid of him um i'm coming off of uh i
think it's
four win streak
ufc buys us um
my managers tell me the story that they
wanted to get rid of him and so they put
and sean's like i know the guy i got the
guy i got the guy he's like this guy
this kid's crazy he can fight with
wrestlers you know and so they sick me
on them you know and i'm going great he
does the interview and he says i'll buy
boy green's a street fighter he doesn't
even know anything about wrestling oh he
didn't do anything he didn't do any like
no background nothing nothing he's like
i've seen i've seen some of his fights
he's just a street fighter okay and at
the time i called my style hood oh
that's funny yeah i used to call it hood
just to throw guys off yeah like no you
just wanna save my boxer you're gonna
take me down yeah if i was saying
wrestle you're gonna stand up yeah i'm
gonna throw you way off i'm just saying
i'm a falsehood you know the street and
he and he bought that marketing he
bought it and so he's going in he
doesn't knock and wrestle we're going at
it
one round um he won the first round and
so i was like i'll be just be patient
you know be patient i feel like he's
going to slow down second round i got
the second round
um i was finishing them up on the second
round i thought i was going to get her
in a second
but the referee stood us up gotcha um
this referee was uh
i don't think she referees in the ufc
before it's the big girl yeah and she
used to do that like touch the nose yeah
yes yeah i don't know what happened bad
girl yeah
um
before we go into this third round uh
did you feel they always call it ufc
jitters did you have the ufc jitters
because obviously strikeforce big
king of the cage big but ufc different
animal you had the ufc debut because you
asked me you asked that question to
yourself do i belong
you know like yeah yeah those are those
shows but this is this show yeah the nfl
how do you see the nfl
sink or swim with the big fish you know
um so yeah i had the jitters i
definitely had the jitters didn't sleep
the first night you know i stayed having
sex with my girlfriend all night so yeah
oh wow yeah that's it i know i was a
little afraid at the moment
at the door like yeah don't have sex
before you fight yeah that broke all
those rules
did not only do you hadn't had fighters
you ran through the rules yeah so let's
get we're here in the third round you're
uh it's it's even he won the first you
win the second not on his face
yeah he's kind of
yeah he was such an interesting bird
back then man
his quarterman's wearing a shirt that
says volkman for president yes that's
what i said it kept attacking the
president these were the wild west days
you had like uh
condom depot on [ __ ] you had to be weird
it would have been chill before chill
but a little bit a little
bit
but it didn't work
that's my boy aaron in the back that's
like my my little brother and [ __ ] i
just bring him in every fight and i just
look at him when we get in the chrome we
just look at each other and that's it he
just gives me the look and
unleash on boom replay that's where the
knot came from yeah
in the second round there and this is
ufc on fox too these were the fox days
so they got big
back when you could wear shorts and
banners you know
the good old days the good old days but
also
it i'll give it to the i'll hand the ufc
and you're talking a guy who was very
against the reebok gear but now that
they have uniforms it does look a lot
better looks a little more professional
very true very true but i just felt like
that gave a character you know
i know
individuality now it's becoming more of
a olympics you know teams you know now
he is the third round you seem way
fresher you're landing he hit you in the
nuts there
he he seems like he's pretty tired yeah
that ref i wonder what happened to her
i want to say it's winslow or something
like that like kelly or carol i just
remember she was she was a big girl like
tall tall and she'd always touch her
nose for some reason yeah yeah i was
like is that like a sign i do cocaine
is that a cocaine sign yeah
yeah i think it was her saying i'm out
of here you know what i'm saying like
i'm moving on to a better career
yeah so you got kicked a nut you don't
take your five minutes
no i'm always back to action you know i
don't want to stop the action i don't
want the crowd to get restless you know
i always feel keep the fight going don't
you that kick was so charlie brown don't
you think it's interesting when you
watch some of these old school fights
like
imagine him in the ufc right now this
isn't a knockout this is what was at the
time but imagine him trying to be like a
nine fit nine fight win streak at 55 now
like the game's evolved so fast you know
kids are so goddamn like you've you've
had to evolve like your game's evolved
and the guys that don't you just watch
these old school fights it's like and
vulcan was a good fighter man yeah he
was a good fighter right there i got him
with a body kick to eat his cardio a
little bit more then i think for the
next bite he tried to take me down i
shut his steak down down and then i had
an inside trip uh off of his takedown
where were you were you talking [ __ ] i
thought we like saying how's the hood
wrestling now dog were you saying any of
that stuff
i think
i'd have to watch again see if i was
talking i just said yes sir you know to
my coaches i let them know i hear them
yeah you don't really not like kevin
holland's style who's talking to trump
yeah yeah yeah i'm not really a [ __ ]
talker you know i believe in being
respectful you know that's the wrestling
unless unless you say something to me
that like
so for instance when i fought in
nazareth narrative when we got in the
cage he said i see fear in your eyes
inside the cage yeah
he's getting ready to fight i'm like oh
so he just sent me another place so
there was a point time where i'm
starting to hit him and i realized
he realized like oh you're going to get
tired i'm like
no you're going to get hit all night
like this and that same night i broke
the record for your most amount of
strength he's a tough character man you
beat somebody else hitting his body
trying to get that body you can see his
tongue down yes look body slow him down
yeah you don't want to get hit in the
face super slow so if you don't get hit
in the face okay i'll just take your
body i mean is that brian callan
fighting they look very similar
the kid but dude for for you i mean for
a debut you seem like you passed with
flying colors you you get a guy who's on
a nine foot nine fight win streak he's
not it's not a great matchup for you but
you're kind of doing work without that
freaking kid yeah but you're reversed
him over yeah that was a sick reverse
and he actually just he was tapping
everybody so that's right i don't think
i know no jiu-jitsu yep
and so people are saying like okay i
caress over vote man i should be able to
wrestle with market chef different
styles of wrestling oh yeah different uh
strength
dynamic i mean
apple to avocado there and that's not a
knock on vulcan but you know those
dagestanians man
they really do so when it comes to
wrestling especially a freestyle usa
wrestler compared to what they do
you know
they're ten steps ahead of us man they
just when you get in that clinch they
have so many weapons they're like swiss
army knives well you have to understand
this
you have to understand that they wrestle
and it's like a a
a cool thing out there it's everything
[ __ ] yeah it's everything yes it's like
what's this like oh what are you guys
doing you guys are gay you're just
wrestling around each other you know to
them it's like you know here you grow up
playing basketball or football hey let's
go wrestle a beer there they wrestle
yeah let's carry these stones up a
mountain you know it's like all right we
got a great idea let's go wrestle beer
guys they're taking over though little
nine-year-old wrestling beers and then
laugh last they all laugh on us man
because they're literally taking over
man they are bro they are you got homs
out at you know 70 coming through
you got makachav you know you're some
you're some killer that's just so
at least with
wait wait shamaya
i feel like he does it in such an
exciting fashion still he's very
exciting you know it says i'm saying
versus that separates him from khabib
and makka chef well look at you talk
about it exciting you you gotta you get
you got mount he rolls to his back and
you got the the rear naked hair
that's called the goldberg right there
when we yeah yeah jeffy goldberg used to
do that back in the day
yeah when he gets to do his finishing
move yeah he'd do that yeah so that's
why he did that yeah i was like i gotta
do the goldberg on him you know joe
silva excited for you because you just
beat the guy that he wanted to lose yeah
yeah such a dick but you know he's doing
a job for you though this uh had to be a
pretty good feather in the cap to get
your first ufc win on fox here against a
tough opponent yeah um the dopest part
about it all
is uh you tap pretty quick there was a
an interview that came out on youtube
and said greenwood envy and it was dana
saying if you want to fight
you need to fight like this if you want
to get to the ufc fight like bobby green
was that was that after this fight or
was this recent fight oh love it love it
and i was just solidified that made me
say oh
i'm in yes you know that gave me the
little like you said you're a guy the
ufc can count on you know what i'm
saying and that's i think that's one of
the reasons which we'll get to after
this this fight with ally quinta but
you know the ufc called your name to
fight mike jeff
and going into that pharaoh if you watch
the show i said man it's not a bad idea
to put some money on bobby green i know
he's a plus 650 but the way he moves and
hits
makachev he's not going to be able to
train for that so there's a there's a
chance where he can land something in
and i think that's why the ufc made that
fight to give fans like
bobby's no punk you know yeah
um and that's the thing too i felt like
i just dialed him in i just got it and
then and that's when everything will
notice though man
against machiavelli you know he's yeah i
don't see anybody beating him man i'm
just i'm just being dead honestly right
now i'm not seeing a lot of
chinks in the armor let's take a little
break from watching some of bobby
green's amazing fights because guess
what a lot of y'all sleeping on these
generic mattresses built just for
anybody but you're not just anybody you
need a mattress that you can sleep on
that is made just for your thick ass why
would you sleep on a mattress made for
somebody else you've been doing that all
your life and you're like i don't know
why i don't feel refreshed i'm not
getting good sleep well i gotcha my
friends at helix sleep got you covered i
have it in my house i have it in all my
rooms i can't get rid of my in-laws my
friends family i thought it was because
they thought i was cool it's not they're
using me for my helix sleep mattresses
and if you want to sleep great and get
the best sleep of your life you need
helix sleep and it's so easy helix sleep
has a quiz it takes two minutes you got
two minutes you do it takes two minutes
to complete and then they match your
body type and the way you sleep with the
perfect mattress just for you not for
joe schmoe joe regular
average joe i'm talking about just for
your thick ass that's right what are you
a side sleeper back sleeper you sleep
hot cold whatever it is helix sleep they
got you covered man it's gonna they're
gonna make the perfect mattress just for
you don't take my word for it helix
sleep was awarded the number one best
overall mattress for 2019 and 2020 by gq
and wired magazine ever heard of them
yeah man
just go to
take their helixsleep.com sleep quiz all
right and they'll match you with a
customized mattress that will give you
the best sleep of your life all right
they have a 10-year warranty you get to
try it out for 100 nights risk-free and
they'll even pick it up if you don't
love it but you will so don't worry
about that helix is offering you guys up
to 200 off all mattress orders and free
pillows for the listeners and viewers of
this show with bobby green helix sleep
dot com slash shob that's
sch
helixsleep.com
for up to 200 off
sleep good sweet prince
let's get back to the show
but ally quinta
this
was an exciting fight new york and his
hometown hometown man
you know al's a colorful dude his own
podcast i love ally quinta
um yeah i love him too yeah this was a
tough one for him though home crowd
did he retire after this one yep yeah so
you you put them in a little bit in
retirement you know as an owl fan and a
fan of yours it's just tough to see man
you know great fight stylistic great
fight but you wonder how much al still
you know wants to do it stuff like that
they give them bobby green in new york
it's a tough fight man me and our
brothers are supposed to fight each
other before um yeah and two weeks
before the fight i blew my knee out
um
oh kind of
said some truth
but he got on my dad
and so true truth in what way because
you guys were
pretty respectful of each other because
i was i respect him he's a veteran it's
a tough fight you know
yeah um but he wasn't like that the
first time you know the first time we
were having our meeting we were younger
then yeah al was a little more wild and
i was wild and so it kind of like we
were talking and we were disrespectful
but he just said some things about my
dad because my dad made a mistake and
said that
ray longo's guys weren't uh homegrown
but those guys come from his gym they're
all from there and so he made a mistake
and they just [ __ ] got him you know
they just went after your dad yeah yeah
and so and i'm like yeah the interview
is really based on me it's not really
him and and but that gives him something
to run on right yeah yeah so al was just
and and his dad
he's trying to steal all the attention
and his dad said i'm like oh okay so i
just never got and then i blew my knee
out two weeks before the fight so i
never got him yeah so you're a weight
sentimental yeah sentimental yeah yeah
hit it mike
and also find that mass square garden
that has to feel good huh
the legends again when you were 16 if i
came up to you and you're and when
you're wearing that uh your crow outfit
with the face paint off i was like yo
man you're me fighting ally quinta and
mass square garden you you would have
you told me i was 16
maybe i would have believed you four
maybe fourteen
when you were with the white boys in
your face
because when i was with the white boy
family yeah not with the white boys no
i'm saying white boys yeah yeah
yeah after that but after that and i
went to the family when i started
staying with the white family all of a
sudden my little brother would tell me
he said you would look yourself in the
mirror it was like you were like telling
yourself you're going to be something
yeah it's dope you know it's like i knew
you're going to be something that makes
sense i'm saying before then while
you're walking the house with the white
boys and you're in fishnets if i was
like yo if i like came back from you
know the future i was like yo man you
may find mass square garden you would
have lost your mind probably took the
fishnets off
or no
you got you got your hair
where your hat dog
yes it gives me my my me
no it's your story i can wear any
[ __ ] thing bro yeah and and be
comfortable with my skin like i'm not
that guy that you can you can rub wrong
oh no i i like that you're you're cut
from a different cloth man one of my
best friends chappelle lacy i don't know
if you know chappelle he's my feature on
the road but you you know it's a little
bit similar store to you
and uh you know one of the greatest
people i know man you know great comic
and then also was raised by a white
family
and his brother also passed away but
you're talking about a kid who
you would look at i'm like oh he's into
this but you know he's in a punk rock
band he wears vans
he's just a different type of dude man
yeah yeah so i like that stuff but
here's you and ally quinta man
um new york mass square garden doesn't
get much bigger than this you guys have
some yeah i guess bad blood you talked
about your dad
and you i mean wait it still was all
respect you know i'm just gonna make you
pay for it in the cage your speed here
man the speed and your hands are down
this is where the thing that al missed
meeting i'll miss this is that alex been
gone
he's been gone for a couple of years
yeah he got a real estate
right you have to understand that the
the the the landscape is changing
the speeds changing they're getting
faster they're getting bigger they're
getting more skilled here they're moving
different they're trying new you know he
doesn't know he's in the he's in the
zone yeah look like yeah right there he
doesn't know he got hit you know right
there he doesn't understand where the
range is at now you're standing too
close now yep you're gonna get hit yep
especially with the your speed advantage
and look look how relaxed you are also
to your point where
the ufc is interesting because it's i
think it's part of conor mcgregor's
issues while he's on this losing streak
is the ufc is different than other
sports you if you take a year off and
try coming back and you're fighting a
dog who's been in there it's a it's just
you there's nothing you do in training
camp that mimics a live fight there's
nothing you can do so it's like that
that just kind of that you know that
ring rust is there man you know how hard
i worked brother to get this style to
put this together there's so many times
that i went in the fights and i felt
like
as if i was watching somebody fight
like that it's not me that i can't do
how i do in the gym
make it look like it looks in the gym
you i mean you are you're it's there i
know you can feel that knockout come
because you're you're oh yeah he's he
look he's not recognizing like you're
like you're serious yeah you're
you're out of it brother you don't
realize the speed look how fast and slow
he's coming back down the shuffle work
there but also um
yeah you're fainted
your fighting style also has a lot to do
with your um
your confidence oh confidence you got to
be a confident dude to fight in a
professional
league with your hands down you got to
be very confident and yes you would be
you got to have you know the skills
yes yes i've been doing this
you know one two down the pipe you know
he wasn't he wasn't respecting the gap
you know and i hit him a couple of times
i'm like he doesn't even know he got hit
he didn't know he was gonna get hit i
just recognized that i'm like okay my
coach like put more on it put more on
he's still standing in front of you hit
him harder yeah and obviously in
hindsight watching the fight like there
was a few times where it's like oh if
bobby decides to really lean into this
this thing's going to be over because
you were lighting them up from the very
you're touching from the beginning like
you said a lot maybe because the long
lay off the ring rust he didn't realize
he was in that danger zone he didn't
really and he didn't realize how fast
things are are moving you know
it's really fast it's really fast boom
you know i mean didn't move his head
after the first punch and that second
punch is what dropped them this too fast
yeah things are going they're happening
really fast in these in in a split
second milliseconds you know that had to
feel good in uh masquerade it was
amazing you know did you do anything
after the fight did you celebrate new
york or no are you a celebration of the
streets i was the joker for
for this fight i came in with joker
painting [ __ ] so i walked through the
streets and i smoked the blood
dressed as a joke
face paint again oh hell yeah chilling
out walking through the streets of new
york like i'm the real life joker i
don't know were you uh were you shocked
that the new yorkers are so used to
people doing that that that demon look
your way oh bro they [ __ ] just love
the guy yeah i bet they loved it though
they loved it that was a big fight and
then here you know again i i don't view
this fight as a negative thing you
fought islam makachev on a 10-day notice
uh the guy's really shown no chinks in
his armor at yeah for me he was just
trying to show some really gangster [ __ ]
bro you know because why
i guarantee you
10 other people got the phone call
before me that's what i was going to say
10 other people got it agree nobody want
to step up oh you guys want to be little
[ __ ] okay watch this move over you
know and i think that goes a long way
with the ufc you gotta hope so with your
your contract being up if i'm your
manager like hey he get come on man he
fought moksha everybody's terrified this
dude he was chilling 190 pounds he made
weight made the main event for you guys
put up performance like what's what's
that worth you know so i think that goes
a long way with them
now what are you thinking here you see
my chef i'm assuming you haven't seen
him before in person
um one time we seen each other in rehab
they were been separating us the whole
time and security around and i was just
getting used to like i really don't care
i don't get bothered by a guy if he came
inside next to me unless he's not it's
not his nature either i don't think his
team was gonna attack you so then he
came
out to me i was sitting somewhere and
he's walking towards me
i'm looking i'm like maybe he's going
he's still coming right so kind of like
get ready and he sticks his hand up
thank you brother thank you oh that's
cool cool he's cool you're respectful
cool you know that's true what i thought
was interesting is in the rda fight on
the last pay-per-view hit uh my uh his
opponent fazeef uh got coveted so he was
out yeah then makcha was like i'll take
the fight and then apparently dana
offered to him and yeah i don't
i in my heart of happiness in there i
don't know what's going on there because
these guys are getting down to fight
whenever so that like danny cameron said
my job i don't know about everybody
though i don't know about all of them
but i know they're down yeah but don't
let don't rub your mind on everybody you
know yeah yeah yeah those guys want
their time dude yeah right stuff yeah
yeah yeah yeah i was just surprising to
take that fight and then he ended up
fighting uh who'd rda fight uh masino
who actually wants to fight you i
actually talked to dana and told then
i'd fill in and fight rda too
you know but now mcconnell goes hey i
took short notice fight yep didn't go my
way bobby took a short notice fight
didn't go my way we should fight each
other yeah you could fight oh monkano
wants opportunity um
am i interested
i want everybody who says my name my
whole thing was like i want to squash
every bug that says my name like yeah
they like the cake but
but
tony ferguson was the first word to say
by name and i would chase him for but i
was ahead of tony at the time when he
was calling me out now i went like this
you think no
he's ranked above me now
i mean if if i mean if we're ranking
ranking-wise but that's what i'm saying
as far as wins go you have more wins
ranking wise now when i was ranked
number six in the world he was still
coming in the vision and obviously he's
calling me and i'm like yeah i'll take
it yeah i want you i'll give you the
opportunity now is switch i'm tony you
wanted to fight hey what's up no no
acknowledgement no i bet he will though
you know no
tony's like you though he showed me he's
seen it no
i see the scene you don't say [ __ ] oh
don't be a little [ __ ] you're gonna
fight now well you said something
chandler next but i've been on this [ __ ]
since you called me yeah you started
this come and finish it yeah but
mcconnell he called your name or do you
think that'd be something or no
uh yeah i guess but did you see what
happened to him
i saw it against rda rda took it
yeah he got easy
up he got beat up he gotta go take a
rest for a second i'm ready to fight
next month yeah you know i'm already
looking at at next month he needs some
time yep you know
i'm looking at exciting stuff you know
uh
like
i still want cowboy
i want cowboy cowboy wrote me wrong uh
joe lozan next i know
that's two vets story tell the fight the
stories
they write all the stories and so i just
don't get my story written the way i
want it written and the way i want it
written before i leave is i get cowboy's
head yeah your story's not done though
you know we're riding it right now my
man
so
look all right he comes out with his
little legs okay
he's fighting scary right now and i'm
not noticing yet throw the leg to keep
you away from me
your style though for to to for makachev
i guarantee you're just totally like
your style's so weird yeah so for mike
he's trying to kind of get me away from
him yeah his team is is not coming i'm
checking in i'm trying here i come i'm
trying to figure it out i'm trying to
figure it out his style different
timings
his team saying you know don't go in
there reckless because bobby has the
power to put you out be smart about it
you know
he's trying to grab me like a
[ __ ] right there hell yeah i got
him off the air okay
so i'm trying to fill him out i love
it's gonna be this one point quick i
love all the tweets by the fires like
let's go bobby like everyone's root for
because everyone knows taking this fight
in short notice is a [ __ ] it's a tall
task man yeah so i'm trying to find my
range
one thing he's doing very well is he's
staying right out there outside just a
kicking range unlike al iaquinta yeah he
knows stays way out and that left that
left is
you can't even touch him
nothing and then he's gonna cover like
so once i hit that body all right now
i'm starting to find him okay i got it
now
look look okay find him myself
now i figured out his hand speed figured
out you just want a leg kick
here
here he comes now look he's he's on it
i'll get him oh god get him
take him down yeah he's just trying to
get you down so now oh okay i blocked
stick down i'm hitting with some knees
okay let's chill i'm like okay just does
he feel strong in the clinch here it
feels strong but i'm not enough nothing
unusual no i'm not nothing like
specifically i'm not okay yeah i should
be going out that way right yep there's
the dart down this is where it goes bad
for you yes i try to go for the damn
choke yep
and i shouldn't went for the choke i
should have been trying to get my hips
away because you were you're out
you were out made a stupid mistake and
one mistake will cost you that's it this
at this level yeah one minute that's all
he just got inch and they're gonna take
him out so look i'm kind of sitting
right here and i'm thinking the knee's
shooting away he's really heavy
really good on top
all he did was these little things watch
you know do a little tweak with his head
this this is the terminator in these
daggers slow it's a slow burn my man i
try to go under him now deep half you
know
yeah
but he's just got a good base good base
yep
so he goes back down this is what he's
been working on and when he's in this
position he's going to go to uh kimura
and you're aware of all this you guys
game planned off yeah yeah and i made
one mistake that i'm wearing he's going
to come or i'm supposed to
snake away then when i re-snicked back
but he mounted me as a resnick right
here watch he's gonna go forward here
he's going for the wrist yep and you
know what's going on yeah you put your
hips the other way all the way there now
he's gonna go now i'm gonna go back the
other way again ah pretty beat me pretty
filthy yeah
now this the only problem i have a
problem with the fight is
one thing i learned is he's really
[ __ ] strong yeah them legs are tight
i'm trying to [ __ ] move and get my
hips hey i can't now so [ __ ] it i turned
over
now i'm stuck here
i'm stuck yeah you're stuck and that's
that's where the ref stops it when you
can't defend yourself but although i'm
like i'm good
yeah i agree they could have let that go
a little longer
just give me a few more seconds i was
just turning to the point where i was
getting back that hard to decide i would
say the difference between makchev and
uh khabib is mak chef stand ups a little
crisper a little more well-rounded and
khabib's
uh wrestling especially as grappling is
it i think they're at the grappling if
makshev is at 10 khabib's in 11. so i
tell him right here i'm like hey you
gotta work on being exciting bro
you just gotta work on being excited
did he
respond to it at all or no i think
you're telling me right now you're like
come on man
hey he didn't know what this [ __ ] was
saying
he's using yeah yeah yeah it's just not
in his nature though yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
it's in your blood to be entertaining
for him he's like i'm just trying to i
just
you shut up
yeah i'm just trying to win a fight and
not i'll see you
talk to me when i got the title yeah
that's exactly the same you know but it
was a big risk for both you man and
again i don't think that's anything to
hang your head on i think the ufc is
going to look at it as a solid and
you're going to negotiations now so
it just and it really sucks to be thrown
in there literally you know there's no
feeling like have you ever had
experience like that where you got
through i never took a short notice
fight no never all my life bro i got 43
fights i say 20 of them at least at
least 20 of them at least lightweight
[ __ ] at heavyweight there's not a lot of
short notices there's just not there
wasn't i mean your first like fight in
ufc was against volk volkman who's a
monster my first fight i was made to
your point about pressure and being main
event my first fight in ufc ever was
against roy nelson you know former world
champion 35 i had four fights
it was just like i'm in this world when
i'm like what is going on can i tell you
something huh i used to didn't like you
really why oh cause uh the ultimate
fighter
um i'm not told it's been fired just
because i just felt like
for my upbringing the football players
you're a football player yeah i just
felt like looking at this football
player trying to coming over in our yeah
in our world you know yeah but then you
earn the respect you know yeah you know
okay he's actually he's actually cool
you know but that i know i get that
even in comedy it's like oh this guy
from podcasting come on dope about you
you're going all kind of worlds bro and
where people would doubt you and you
[ __ ] kill it yep yep that's the plan
that's amazing yeah i'm used to it but
see i converted everybody we're friends
now
thanks for watching the fights man we're
going to do this again i'm sure we're
going to watch three other great fights
because you got a lot of fight left in
you i got three more this year at least
yeah that's your style man so thanks for
doing this man bobby green
[Music]
george everybody make plays break lanes
push weight break chains go hard kick
ass take names